[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
prélude à une rencontre de gaulle
bourguiba relance d'une solution au
problème algérien
la réception à l'elysée de monsieur
masmoudi ministre tunisien de
l'information a été l'un des faits les
plus commentées de la semaine
[Musique]
réception du chancelier adenauer marque
est elle une autre relance celle de
l'europe
le long entretien que le chef du
gouvernement de bonn devait avoir avec
le général de gaulle aura permis
d'harmoniser les conceptions française
et allemande à la veille de la réunion
des six
[Musique]
les responsables des six pays du marché
commun avaient rendez vous au quai
d'orsay pour ce qu'on peut appeler la
première conférence européenne au sommet
quelle forme revêtira l'organisation
politique de l'europe
rien est encore apparents mais l'idée
est en marche
m
à orly air france avait réservé une
surprise au millionième passager
transporté par caravane c'est ainsi que
monsieur juan espinho de madrid est
devenu en posant le pied sur le sol
parisien propriétaire d'une voiture 1
millions de passagers
c'est pour les caravelles un parcours
équivalent à 493 fois le tour de la
terre à villennes sur seine près de
paris
les pluies récentes ont miné le sol
d'une colline et une masse argileux
s'est mise à glisser entraînant tout sur
son passage
un cratère de 20 mètres de diamètre
s'ouvre aujourd'hui devant la villa qui
couronne le sommet de la colline et qui
menace de s'écrouler
l'avalanche qui avance de 2 mètres par
24 heures et qui représente des milliers
de tonnes menace les villas construites
dans la vallée de nouvelles pluies
provoquerait maintenant une avalanche
désastreuse et les riverains jeter dans
une inquiétude compréhensible des
ménages au plus vite de leur immeuble en
péril
[Musique]
la sauvage passe de khaybar l'un des
principaux passages entre le pakistan et
l'afghanistan s'est soudain animer les
montagnards pakistanais étaient venus
saluer une visiteuse de marque
la reine elizabeth qui poursuit en
compagnie du prince philip son voyage en
asie
[Musique]
la passe de khaybar est un lieu
doublement historique qui rappelle de
grands souvenirs
la pacer les armes et d'alexandre le
grand là aussi furent massacrés dans une
embuscade au siècle dernier
seize mille soldats de sa majesté
britannique
[Musique]
ceci n'est qu'une carte mais c'est une
carte suisse petits détails devront
découler toutes sortes de conséquences
plus surprenantes les unes que les
autres
après l'huile de vidange et l'eau froide
l'épreuve de la roue pour laquelle on a
soigneusement choisi un terrain de
boules
mais pourquoi cet acharnement direz vous
c'est très simple si l'on soumette une
carte ordinaire c'est-à-dire imprimé sur
un papier classique à la moitié de ces
brutalités
elle n'y résistera pas tant s'en faut
[Musique]
ce qui est loin d'être le cas de la
première carte imprimée elle sur un
papier à base de fibres synthétiques est
garantie par l' usine qu'ils fabriquent
lavables et corvéables à merci
le papier idéal par conséquent pour les
cartes topographiques les pièces
d'identité
les actes notariés voir les feuilles
d'impôts
[Musique]
m
mais l'expérience peut aller plus loin
et voici notre carte tordu comme une
corde voué à soulever une voiture avec
ses quatre occupants
[Musique]
s'il reste un doute après tout cela sur
les qualités de résistance de ce papier
on le dit à taipei capitale de formose
les enfants aveugles ont aussi leurs
épaules mais ici apprendre à lire n'est
sans doute pas aussi facile qu'ailleurs
si l'on songe au nombre de caractères
que comporte l'écriture chinoise
pour le reste les petits aveugle de
taipei s'instruisent comme ceux de
londres ou de paris
les travaux pratiques il est vrai
destiné à les préparer à un métier futur
sont largement teinté de régionalisme à
l'art du tricot
s'ajoute aussi l'art de la presse
et d'autres spécialités sont enseignés
comportant à côté du métier de ma soeur
celui d' acupuncteur comme il se doit
puisque l'acupuncture nous vient de
chine
[Musique]
paysages naïf univers poétique c'est
rousseau c'est rousseau toujours cette
étrange petit bonhomme tout seul dans un
monde chargé de secret cette petite
ambre l'âme innocente de rousseau on la
retrouvera dans ses oeuvres qui valent
aujourd'hui des millions et qui furent
vendues quelques francs
[Musique]
et
là
il naquit en 1844 à laval dans la tour
droite de la porte de jaurès où son père
exerçait le métier de ferblantier et qui
depuis s'est enrichi d'une plaque à son
nom
c'est là qu'il vécut son histoire ses
premières années avant d'entrer au lycée
de sa ville on ne pense pas qu'il y fut
un très brillant élève ses années de
collège le menèrent jusqu'au régime at
il pris part à l'expédition du mexique
où il aurait découvert le goût des
tropiques
c'est peu probable mais il fit la guerre
de 70 et fut paraît-il nommé sergent sur
le champ de bataille ce n'est pas sûr
non plus ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
avait en 1869 épouser clémence boitard
de saint germain en laye pour laquelle
il composa pour mandoline ou violents
cette valse qui n'ajoute rien à sa
gloire il rappelle en même temps du
papier chez un huissier qui l'abandonna
pour entrer dans l'administration de
l'octroi ce livret de tarifs qui fut le
sien l'accompagnant pendant les années
qu'il passa dans la guérite de la porte
de vanves et c'est à cet emploi qu'il
dut le surnom de douaniers dont
guillaume apollinaire devait plus tard
le gratifier
[Musique]
devenu veuf il prit sa retraite et 20
logé dans la pauvre humain singes et aux
rixes où tout est resté comme il le
connu par cet escalier sordide il
montait à son atelier ou s'estompait
toutes les ombres d'une vie médian l'art
maintenant occupe toute sa vie ils
essaient d'ajouter en donnant des cours
quelques freins à sa retraite
proportionnelle mais il est souvent en
dette avec son marchand de couleurs
sa vie c'est le tableau qu'il peint
c'est la magic réalité de ces évocations
c'est cette jungle qu'il n'a jamais vu
qu'à travers le journal des voyages elle
le mènera à travers son illumination
quotidienne jusqu'à sa mort en 1910 à
l'hôpital necker will est simplement
qu'un pauvres qui meurent parmi les
pauvres il reposera pas à laval sous la
pierre ou le sculpteur brancusi gravats
l'adieu d'apollinaire gentil rousseau tu
nous entends nous apporterons des
pinceaux des couleurs et des toiles afin
que tes loisirs sacré dans la lumière
réel que les consacre à peindre comme tu
tires à mon portrait la phase des
étoiles
et aujourd'hui cette exposition qui est
la plus importante réalisée jusqu'ici et
dont les 80 tableaux sont assurés pour 8
milliards d'anciens francs n'a même plus
à consacrer le jean qui rousseau comme
l'un des maîtres de la peinture moderne
on pourra rêver devant la noce on pourra
rêver devant le portrait de l'authie à
cette destinée mystérieuse si modeste
dans son acheminement quotidien si
bouleversante dans sa portée artistique
il avait le don céleste d'imaginer il a
donc vécu son rêve sans se soucier des
rires et des sarcasmes que faisait
naître sa peinture il admirait beau gros
mais il peignait avec honnêteté comme un
gentil rousseau qu'il était et c'est lui
qui en définitive a eu raison
[Musique]
on rêvera donc devant le monde qui a
ouvert cet art qui ne trouvaient ses
seules certitudes que dans son coeur on
rêvera devant ce petit bonhomme tout
seul dans la vie tout seul avec son
innocence secret
[Musique]
[Rires]